holiday shopping in full swing and if
you're looking for toys that help your
kids with their stem skills or encourage
recycling our mommy blogger and
lifestyle expert gives us a breakdown of
some hot items
[Music]
parents scrambling to find toys for kids
of all ages that help them be creative
and don't break the bank mom of three
Amanda mushrow reveals her top choices
we have the creative holiday Classics
and this is such a fun little kit so the
idea is that they'll get all of these
pieces and they put together these 4D
ornaments and they actually get a string
of lights so they can put it together
hang it on their tree it's really fun
putting those stem skills to use these
stocking stuffers also have other shapes
so once the holidays are over kids can
use them as a nightlight baba Boo and
Friends Wooden play figures and books
get parents reading with their Kids
introducing them to characters and
themes plus mushro says the wooden toys
don't make noise when toys make noise we
get quiet and our kids get quiet so if
we have these wooden toys they're more
chatty whether they're using those first
words or babbling so I love that idea of
like starting that language the plus
plus learn to build set is a great stem
toy to help develop fine motor skill
skills focus and patience put together
these 3D and 4D unicorns and creatures
and rainbows or they can just get super
creative and make their own things up
and I like this idea if you have anybody
who is traveling for the holidays you
can take the little plus plus you can
put them into a bag if they're going to
be flying or in the car and gives them a
nice quiet activity and for the tweener
teen who still loves a plush stuffed
animal what I love about these is that
they are made out of completely recycled
water bottles consider wild republics
plush animals with pop art graphics and
messages about saving our planet
also she says the Truffle wooden craft
origin puzzle and the mobile Triton Pro
recumbent adult trike also very popular
for the young at heart